[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actu l'assemblée et au
sénat
et pour ce dernier numéro de 2019 et
pour commenter toute la semaine passée
notre invité aujourd'hui sylvain
maillard bonjour bonjour à vous vous
êtes débuté la république en marche de
paris porte parole du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale et on va commencer
par brosser votre portrait sylvain
maillard bonjour alors en quelques
traits de plume vous êtes né à
saint-maur-des-fossés dans le
val-de-marne vous êtes un entrepreneur
école supérieure de commerce erasmus en
allemagne de retour en france vous
fondez votre société en 2001 à 27 ans
vous avez aussi la politique alors vous
rejoignez la famille centriste ses
avatars udf nouveau centre udi
et puis en 2017 vous choisissez de faire
campagne pour emmanuel macron vous êtes
l'un des jeunes visages de la république
en marche issu du monde de l'entreprise
vous êtes élu député de paris et par
ailleurs conseiller de paris et vous
avez intégré l'équipe de benjamin
griveaux pour les municipales alors la
conquête de paris c'est en mars comment
s'annonce la bataille en quelques mots
alors la bataille s'annonce comme
n'importe quelle est la conquête oui
d'abord juste vous dire que je suis pas
conseiller de paris j'étais que maire
adjoint dans le 9e arrondissement le
d'abord c'est une une belle une belle
campagne parce que c'est une campagne
qui nous permet de dire aux parisiens ce
que nous portons est ce que nous voulons
porter pour paris où le constat général
c'est que la vie s'est largement
dégradée depuis cinq ans et quelles sont
les perspectives que nous portons avec
benjamin griveaux et il va être
compliqué entre benjamin griveaux est
aussi cédric villani à deux députés du
même groupe dont vous faites partie vous
savez à chaque fois que il campagne à
paris ce n'est jamais simple
la réalité c'est que c'est jamais sous
le monde pour la droite il cette
campagne différente parce qu'il ya un
seul arrondissement
arrondissement centre et donc c'est
toujours compliqué mais l'essentiel
c'est de parler aux parisiens c'est ce
que fait benjamin griveaux et de porter
un projet un projet d'amélioration la
vie au quotidien
eh bien on va revenir en tout cas pour
l'heure sur l'actualité parlementaire
cette semaine avec toujours à la une est
bien le dossier des retraites
on reviendra avec vous sur les
négociations tendues entre les
partenaires sociaux et le gouvernement
la consigne de retour le gouvernement a
rétabli cette mesure controversée dans
le projet de loi examiné à l'assemblée
qui vise à lutter contre le gaspillage
et puis la proposition de loi contre la
haine sur internet était aussi à l'ordre
du jour cette semaine les sénateurs ont
réécrit la version votée à l'assemblée
et on commence par le dossier à la une
qui arrivera au parlement au printemps
la réforme de la colère
[Musique]
énième réunion à matignon edouard
philippe a retrouvé les partenaires
sociaux pas d'annoncés concrètes en tout
cas officiellement du premier ministre
mais un nouveau rendez vous fixé en
janvier à la sortie c'est la division la
cfdt l'unsa ont choisi la trêve dans la
grève mais la cgt et sud rail
maintiennent la pression
écoutez edouard philippe à la sortie de
matignon ce jeudi j'ai écouté et entendu
les critiques dès les premiers jours de
janvier avec le secrétaire d'état nous
consulterons les partenaires sociaux et
je proposerai mi janvier
une méthode qui nous permettra soit
d'atteindre un accord qui pourrait se
substituer à la solution que j'ai
proposé soit à tout le moins d'améliorer
celles ci en tenant compte des
propositions des syndicats
alors si l'un derrière à l'issue des de
cette énième tour de négociations à
matignon il n'y a pas on a l'impression
qu'il n'y a pas d'avancées très concrète
puisque désaccord persiste est ce que
pour vous les lignes sont en train de
bouger
ou est-ce que la guerre de position le
bras de fer va encore durer longtemps
qu'elle est enfin sinon il n'y a pas un
front syndical syndical il ya différents
syndicats qui ont des positions
finalement assez contrasté on a des
syndicats at-il cgt force ouvrière qui
ne veulent pas de cette réforme qu'ils
ont dit très clairement qu'ils depuis
plusieurs mois le disent et restent dans
leur position on ne veut pas de
changement préfère un système qui est
profondément injuste comme il est à
l'heure actuelle et qui n'est pas
financé ça c'est leur position
et puis d'autres des syndicats
réformistes comme la cfdt l'unsa la cftc
qui eux sont ouverts d'abord sont
d'accord avec les principes de la
réforme à point que chaque euro cotisé
donne les mêmes droits
par contre sont sur des certaines
attentes l'âge pivot entre autres c'est
ce dont on a beaucoup parlé mais en
réalité il ya beaucoup de discussions
sur la pénibilité sur la longueur des
carrières et la coulisse évidemment
qu'il ya des directions officiellement
et en coulisse adressé justement aux
syndicats particulièrement à la ratp à
la sncf
sur quoi ça peut bouger
justement pour pour débloquer la
situation au niveau des transports oui
je crois que les longues carrières la
pénibilité c'est des choses qui sont
attendus et sur lequel il y à des
discussions à l'heure actuelle où il
faut trouver un point d'équilibré pour
qu'on puisse sortir de cette de ce
conflit de ce conflit dure
après on se fait pas d'illusion on sait
qu'une partie des syndicats sont contre
la réforme
de toute façon et ne sont pas dans la
négociation ce que l'on veut c'est
ramener le plus possible de deux
syndicats vers une réforme co construite
ensemble parce que nous portons je crois
à la réforme la plus sociale du
quinquennat et et que est très souvent
elle a été caricaturée dans les médias
ou ailleurs parce que probablement plein
de raisons mais mais la réalité c'est
que nous devons nous entendre dessus
parce qu'il ya des vraies avancées
sociales et et que les syndicats sonore
à allaient l'accompagner pour l'instant
l'opinion publique est encore favorable
au mouvement social
comment est ce que vous pouvez garantir
aux gens qui ne vont pas y perdre parce
que manifestement c'est leur crainte
c'est comme ça qu'il faut pas rentrer
dans la dans la réforme si je puis me
permettre
d'abord quand vous regardez les sondages
ils sont ils sont très contrastées parce
que les la plupart des français très
largement ne veulent plus de régimes
spéciaux et à côté sont plutôt en
soutient encore majoritairement de de la
grève mais tout en se disant bien que la
plupart des français ne sont pas
impactés au quotidien regrette moi qui
suis député de paris je peux vous
assurer que c'est un mouvement très dur
et proclamé la vie des franciliens est
vraiment chamboulée depuis plusieurs
semaines pouvant donc il faut absolument
que nous puissions en sortir il ya cette
peur face à cette réforme dont on voit
mal les contours chacun se demande dans
les transports mais ce que j'ai gagné
les femmes par exemple est-ce qu'elles
vont gagner ce qu'elles vont perdre
on a l'impression que les choses sont
pas très claires vous avez dit qu'à ce
stade les grandes gagnantes mais
finalement quand on sait salaires
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça oui les
femmes d'abord sont les grandes
perdantes du système à l'heure actuelle
car en les pensions sont en moyenne de
40 2% inférieures à celles des hommes
dans le système actuel nous ce que nous
voulons c'est d'abord pour une partie
mais ça c'est déjà d'autres lois et que
nous avons porté notamment sur l'avenir
l'avenir professionnel faire en sorte
que les salaire égal ou compétence égale
travail égales on ait le même salaire
entre une des femmes et des hommes déjà
c'est un premier pas franchi qui doit
être accompagnée qui nous permettra de
rétablir une retraite égale mais en même
temps les femmes ont plus souvent des
carrières heurter les femmes sont plus
20 % d'entre elles vont travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans à l'heure actuelle grâce
à notre réforme on va s'arrêter à 64 ans
et avec cet âge pivot qui était donné
par le premier ministre et donc qui
permettra une vraie avancée
moi je crois qu'il fait quand même
controverse et hp c'est un peu moins dur
de la réponse vous avez raison mais vous
savez pour le moment les syndicats comme
les différentes réformes
elle traite toujours bien de ceux qui
sont bien dans le système ceux qui ont
des carrières finalement très lisse très
parfaitement vu de toutes parts contre
les carrières heurter les carrières plus
compliqué les changements de poste
change de statut et et nous et encore
plus les jeunes auront différents
emplois différents statuts différentes
carrières et qu'il faut vous pouvoir
accompagner
c'est pas normal qu'aucun d'entre nous
sur ce plateau où vous téléspectateurs
sage en réalité à moins d'avoir être
dans une quête à une carrière des
enseignants ou des choses très très
encadrée bon c'est n'ai aucune idée de
la pension qu'il aura ça c'est pas juste
et c'est ça qui est demain on l'envoie
de l'avenir et je termine là dessus les
jeunes à l'heure actuelle dans dans le
même sondage dont vous parlez les jeunes
sont majoritairement favorables à la
capitalisation
ce que nous ne voulons pas c'est dire
qu'ils n'ont pas confiance dans le
système
à l'heure actuelle il faut le
transformer est ce qu'il ya de la
friture entre l'elysée et matignon sur
le dossier le communiqué de l'elysée en
plein début des rencontres bilatérales
d'edouard philippe mercredi comment
est-ce qu'il faut l'interpréter
je peux vous assurer qu'il n'y a pas une
feuille de papier cigarette d'écart
entre la position du premier ministre
est celle du président de la république
ils travaillent main dans la main
l'elysée matignon travaillent main dans
la main que parfois des conseillers
pareloup que des journalistes extra
peut-être dépenser ou d'une mauvaise
formulation ça peut arriver à tous la
réalité c'est que le couple exécutif
fonctionne parfaitement sur cette
réforme comme sur les autres
le premier ministre fait en sorte que
cette réforme aboutisse sur les voeux du
premier et du président un public silva
manière tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
des conséquences pour paris notamment de
la grève justement lors de la séance de
questions d'actualité au sénat la
sénatrice catherine dumas a interpellé
le gouvernement sur les mesures qu'il
compte prendre pour aider les
commerçants parisiens impacté par la
grève
écoutez les chiffres de cette première
moitié du mois sont inquiétants moins
80% pour les commerces situés dans les
gares ou à proximité 50% dans les
magasins parisiens 30% dans les hôtels
avec une cascade d'annulations en
moyenne près de deux tiers des artisans
ou commerçants franciliens se déclare
impactés vous avez donné quelques
chiffres ces chiffres ne représentent
pas totalement la réalité commerciale en
particulier vous avez des commerçants
qui s'en sortent très bien d'autres qui
sont en grande difficulté
et puisque vous aborder la situation de
paris j'aimerais également voir des
prises de position plus forte de la part
de la mairie à qui nous avons donné six
cent mille euros pour la relance
commerciale et qui à ce stade n'a pas
affiché de volonté ni de revoir le sujet
des parkings ni des circulations ni des
terrasses je vous remercie
comment est-ce que vous réagissiez
justement à la demande qu'a faite anne
hidalgo qui demande d indemnisation de
la part du gouvernement et bien face à
la grève à l'impact que cela pour les
commerçants parisiens
d'abord moi je voudrais qu anne hidalgo
a accompli son travail de maire n'ont
pas de candidat tout futur candidat de
mer c'est-à-dire d'accompagner les
commerçants ce qu'a dit catherine une
maille tout à fait juste accompagnent
les commerçants les hôteliers les salles
de spectacles qui sont énormément
impactées à l'heure actuelle rien qu'ils
font il ne fait rien elle n'accompagne
pas très clairement il n'y a pas
d'accompagnement le droit de suspendre
le paiement du droit terrasse par
exemple serait quelque chose de très
positif de faire en sorte que des
emplacements de parking soit gratuit
pour les commerçants qui doivent venir
de très loin souvent il même si on
pourrait en parler de la politique du
logement à paris mais il qu'ils
devraient et qui devrait leur permettre
de les amis rentrent aussi les âmes des
amendes ou tout continue comme si on
voit bien que la maire de paris n'a
qu'accompagne le chaos qu'on a vu dans
paris on lui demande d'être beaucoup
plus facilitantes sur le fond les
commerçants sont impactés c'est vrai que
c'est un rôle aussi du gouvernement hier
j'étais moins avec agnès pannier rue
nash et nous étions au marché d'aligre
12e pour aller voir directement les
commerçants et et de présenter aussi les
brigades mobiles c'est-à-dire que et on
a mis en place des binômes qui ils sont
disponibles pour l'ensemble des
commerçants d'ailleurs je fais un appel
aux commerçants parisiens des brigades
mobiles avec la cci de paris avec la
chambre des métiers et de l'artisanat
qui sont là pour aider à remplir les
cerfa qui est très simple un document
très simple qui permet de mesurer les
pertes de haut de la du chiffre
d'affaires des impactante qui sont dues
aux manuels serait forte pour vous il ya
vraiment des pertes sur metz on peut les
chiffrer elles sont c'est toujours
compliqué on a on a fait deux années de
suite entre les gilet jaune l'année
dernière et là cette année à la grèce
avant le mois de décembre on a la chance
à paris d'avoir un tissu de commerçants
bien plus importants à 23000 commerçants
on a 8000 à londres rendez compte la
différence mais on a un tissu commercial
qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus fragiles
qui a été très fragilisés de l'année
dernière par les gilet jaune qu'il ait à
nouveau il nous faut l'accompagner nous
l'accompagnons nous sommes là et je leur
lance un appel en disant ne pas hésiter
à se retourner vers leurs cci vers les
sites du ministère pour justement
demandé une indemnisation ou pour la
plupart d'entre eux un report de charge
qui permet de gagner la trésorerie
reports de charges ou report
d'imposition essais des mesures
continuent de réclamer mon meilleur chez
les jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils ont mais
300 millions sur la table pour reporter
et faire en sorte qu'ils puissent passer
cette mauvaise passe alors si l'on aille
art deuxième grand sujet à l'ordre du
jour et bien c'est le projet de loi qui
vise à lutter contre le gaspillage les
députés l'ont adopté ce jeudi en
première lecture
[Musique]
le texte inscrit notamment dans la loi
l'objectif de 100% de plastiques
recyclés d'ici au 1er janvier 2000 25
il vise aussi l'interdiction de mise sur
le marché des emballages plastiques à
une âge à usage unique d'ici 2040 la
consigne a aussi fait son retour dans le
texte mais avec une certaine marge de
manoeuvre pour les collectivités locales
comme nous l'expliquent fanny die mesure
chère au gouvernement
la consigne est devenu l'un des points
de crispation majeur du débat sur le
projet de loi anti gaspillage supprimé
par les sénateurs qui ont examiné le
texte en octobre
elle a été réintégrée par les députés
par le biais d'un amendement
gouvernemental
la consigne ne sera pas imposé mais les
collectivités territoriales auront
jusqu'à 2023 pour satisfaire aux
objectifs de recyclage des bouteilles en
plastique fixées par l'union européenne
en clair 77 % en 2025 et 90% en 2029
si les collectivités n'y parviennent pas
l'état pourra éventuellement leur
imposer la mesure que prévoit cet
amendement il donne rendez-vous en 2023
pour faire un bilan d'étape et décider
du déploiement de dispositifs de
consignes en cas d'écart à la
trajectoire cible
dans l'intervalle il permet de lancer
des expérimentations de consignes sur
les territoires volontaire mais sur les
bancs de la droite
la mesure ne concerne pas les
collectivités se sentent floués
à la lecture de l'amendement du
gouvernement que vous dites résulter
d'une concertation mais qui ont en fait
ne l'est pas il convient donc de
remédier au caractère inéluctable de la
consigne pour recyclage
l'opposition de gauche elle dénonce une
disposition influencé par les géants
industriels trois grands groupes que
sont danone avec evian et volvic entre
autres que son essai waters avec vital
et perrier que son coca cola a eu avec
santa esprit c'est eux c'est eux qui ont
mis en oeuvre cette directive européenne
et maintenant c'est eux qui agissent
auprès du gouvernement pour aller dans
le sens notamment de l'article vous
portez c'est pas l'environnement qui les
intéressent
ce qui les intéresse c'est leur profit
après deux heures de discussions la
consigne est votée avec 100 voix pour et
159 contre
députés et sénateurs se réuniront au
début de l'année prochaine pour tenter
de trouver un compromis
un accord n'est pas garanti alors si
jean nayar le 19 novembre dernier devant
les maires réunis en congrès emmanuel
macron avait dit sur un sujet
particulièrement sensible comme celui de
la consigne rien ne sera fait sans
l'accord des maires on croyait avoir
compris qu'elle était plus ou moins
abandonnée la voici qu'il resurgit
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre et
pourquoi est elle là dans ce texte je
crois que c'est vraiment dans la lignée
du discours présidentiel
on a écouté les collectivités locales
qui étaient contre le vase dire des
choses ici contre la consigne
oui qui étaient contre en 10 ans on a
parfois avec des avec des réponses
variées des bourses arguments en trop
dans dix ans on a beaucoup investi
oui dans le jeu ce traitement du déchet
dans le recyclage est donc derrière
si on a plus suffisamment de matière en
fait plastique on ne peut plus trouver
nos équilibres
donc il faut qu'on puisse sortir dans
une transition douce qui permettent de
passer d'un système à l'autre nous c'est
ce qu'on a adopté dans cette dans cet
article qui permet d'avoir d'un objectif
2025 on avec plusieurs étapes mais qui
permet d'expérimenter position de la
mesure collectivités exactement les
collectivités vont pouvoir dans pouvoir
s'en saisir ou pas certaines
collectivités sont plus en amont ou bien
ont moins investi en fait dans le
recyclage est donc vous pouvoir
directement partir sur la consigne ou
bien d'autres ont peut-être là titre
expérimental s'en saisir et puis voir
quelles sont l'organisation qu'il faut
mais quelle est l'organisation qu'il
faut mettre en place
et puis trouver un modèle économique ils
voyaient déjà l'opposition du sénat qui
appelle à ce que vous respectiez la
parole du président de la république ce
communiqué qu'ils ont sorti hier en
disant que vous ne vous ne la respectez
pas avec ce dispositif car ce sera
l'état qui prendra au final la mois si
les collectivités ne suivent pas
trajectoire non mais qu'on soit d'accord
l'objectif il est évidemment de sortir
de cette société du tout jetable et donc
on donne plus de temps pour s'organiser
aux collectivités on les a parfaitement
entendu on sait que ça prend du temps on
demande à chacun d'entre deux d'entre
elles de s'en saisir et de faire en
sorte de trouver son rythme
elles pour pouvoir sortir du tout
jetable on donne une issue quand même
relativement lointaine chacun va avancer
dessus mais je crois qu'il ya pas de
bonne ou mauvaise position il ya à
écouter sur le terrain les acteurs
locaux
juste un mot sur le fait que cela est
tournée on a entendu dans le sujet à la
bataille sur le sujet des lobbys et
qu'on juge que le gouvernement ait porté
par le lobby a notamment de coca cola
par exemple qu'est ce que vous répondez
vous savez quand on n'a plus d'arguments
je me suis énervé hier dans l'hémicycle
sur celui là quand on n'a plus
d'arguments on dit toujours que l'autre
est pris par un lobby ça c'est une
réponse à andré chassaigne andré
chassaigne a d'autres qui j'ai autres
d'autres longs bordés le député lambert
le porter aussi régulièrement contre la
ministre c'est insupportable on peut
avoir des désaccords ont des désaccords
politiques c'est l'endroit pour les
accords politiques dans l'hémicycle en
eau en aucun cas l'injure parce que
quelque part c'est tenter d'injurier de
déstabiliser la position des uns et des
autres au contraire je crois que c'est
une position des coudes que nous avons
eue de pragmatisme faire en sorte que
l'écologie que le recyclage que la
consigne s'incarne concrètement que le
dernier kilomètre soit réalisée et qu'
on puisse faire cette transformation
écologique on appelle tous de nouveau on
verra bien d'ici là ce qui va se passer
de vivriers sur le plat car il tient ses
de l'inde objet concret de classiques
dans les deux prochaines années vont
disparaître c'est ce que nous avons venu
aussi les tout y est les gobelets qui ai
plus rien donné 40 et exactement
allez on avance on avance tranquillement
mais sereinement et le plastique va
disparaître fermeture alors cette
semaine l'assemblée a définitivement
adopté le budget pour 2020 après plus de
deux cent quarante huit heures de
discussions auprès de près de 9000
amendements il n'y a pas eu d'accord en
revanche avec les sénateurs qui ont
rejeté le texte sans débattre des
articles les députés ont donc eu le
dernier mot comme souvent alors recruter
et ce projet de loi on dit que c'est un
projet de loi l'un projet de budget pour
le pouvoir d'achat
ou alors pour les gilet jaune parce
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de mesures
qui ont été prises après la crise
sociale sais c'est quoi comme ben oui je
crois que ses dirigeants un budget pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français
petit les jaunes ou pas est ce que nous
avons entendu les gilet jaune
d'une façon plus générale une
contestation de gens qu'il n'y arrivait
pas qu'ils travaillaient qu'il casse du
mois travaillé durement tous les jours
et le 15 du mois n'avait plus d'argent
pour finir le
donc on a accompagné des mesures fortes
17 milliards qu'on était allé vous
revendiquez continue cet investissement
mais c'est aussi le budget des baisses
d'impôts 5 milliards de baisses d'impôts
pour les particuliers je pense que c'est
quelque chose de fondamental de faire en
sorte que non seulement nous baissions
les impôts nous redonnions du pouvoir
d'achat aux français
et nous accompagnons les grands dossiers
on vient de parler les dix jours plus
tard alors la réduction des déficits
pour plus tard je crois que quand vous
regardez les chiffres nous avons
stabilisé nous baisserons le déficit
l'année proche alors on peut toujours
discuter du rythme attention il faut
tout financé aussi il n'y a pas d'argent
magique
je crois que nous avons fait raisonnable
mais un budget d'ambition en tout cas
moi je suis très fier de porter ce
budget sylvain maillard on va passer au
dernier thème de cette émission l'examen
au sénat de la proposition de loi de la
députée laetitia via luttant contre la
haine en ligne
[Musique]
la chambre haute a largement détricoté
ce texte qui avait été adoptée à
l'assemblée
droite et gauche ont jugé le texte
dangereux pour les libertés
individuelles
sandra cerqueira lutter contre la haine
sur internet
le sujet fait consensus mais dans la
pratique le texte de la députée lrm
laetitia avia est accusé par le sénat de
mettre à mal la liberté d'expression
bruno retailleau reproche à la loi de
confier la censure au géant du net est
de créer une société de surveillance
généralisée plus vous nous proposez de
leur confier ce que ce que nous avons de
plus précieux c'est à dire la censure de
privatiser la censure c'est vouloir
demander de nous réguler et de réguler
une de loubert libertés publiques qui
est importante pour nous français et
cela ne va pas et vous la proposer cette
censure non pas des hommes ou des femmes
et à des robots à des algorithmes dont
nous ne connaîtrons jamais les codes
sources mes chers collègues
voilà le problème les sénateurs ont donc
supprimer la mesure phare de la
proposition de loi qui veut obliger les
plateformes a retiré en 24 heures tous
contenus signalés comme et nous sous
peine de sanctions la gauche n'a pas non
plus ménagé sa peine pour dénoncer le
texte nous proposons que le retrait soit
dans un délai de 24 heures nous gardons
donc cette mesure phare mais que si la
personne qui a notifié ce protest le
juge des référés doit être saisie
immédiatement par la plate forme et dans
ce cas le retrait provisoire
nous tenons à égale distance la lutte
contre les contenus haineux et la lutte
pour préserver la liberté d'expression
et ainsi trouver ce juste équilibre qui
n'a pas été trouvée dans le texte
initial
malgré les critiques le secrétaire
d'état au numérique a défendu la
nécessité du texte estimant que c'est un
problème de santé publique
lorsque ce qui les agressent se sentent
ignorés par les autorités et peu à vue
peuvent agir quasiment impunément
alors c'est le douloureux syndrome de
notre échec et de notre impuissance et
c'est pour nous tous mais d'abord pour
l'état une lourde responsabilité
la majorité sénatoriale a en revanche
approuvé le renforcement de la
régulation des plateformes sous la
supervision
du conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel en
sur les 160 signalements de contenus
illicites en ligne près de 14000
relevait de la haine en ligne ou de
discrimination sylvain maier votre
réaction au sort réservé par le sénat ce
texte il l'a vidé de sa substance et de
sa mesure principale l'obligation pour
les plateformes de retirer sous 24
heures les contenus un manifestement
illicite ils ont craint un risque de sur
100 sur moi je crois que le sénat
honnêtement est à côté de la plaque est
à côté de la plaque dans les libertés en
dit en faisant des discussions en
chambre de sur ce qu'est la loi et de
une vision je crois que c'est exactement
ce que les citoyens n'accepte plus de la
politique ne croient plus en la parole
politique justement à cause de deux de
telle position pour quoi concrètement
quand vous allez sur internet la haine
c'est clairement installé effet nous
polluent nos systèmes no no no no no le
tweeter les facebook multi sociaux sont
devenus honnêtement des poubelles se
sont ni des poubelles des insultes en
permanence qu'est ce qui se passe au
début on videra c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave la réalité c'est que c'est ça
qui hystérie aussi notre société où donc
sur les réseaux sociaux on peut dire
n'importe quoi
non on peut pas dire n'importe quoi non
avoir des insultes vous savez que j'ai
porté un texte sur le lutte contre
l'antisémitisme d un tuyau avait
d'ailleurs fait débat sur votre vie
actuelle à la limite bien sûr des
insultes antisémites
il n'est pas normal qu'elle puisse
finalement prospérer sur sur internet en
attendant qu'un juge se prononce de ces
essais marqués dans le toit il faut
c'est ce dernier kilomètre de de clarté
de dire ce qui est acceptable de ce qui
n'est pas acceptable doit être inscrite
dans la loi
nous reprenons le texte et nous
revoterons l'article 1 de macolin
l'assemblée quand le texte exactement
sur des tricots très ce qu'ont fait les
sales après sa virée là exactement où on
a une position très claire on ne peut
pas accepter on veut qu'ils se soient
efficaces et de faire en sorte que cette
haine sur internet qui se diffuse après
dans le réel
cette semaine sur internet soit
interdite mais pour être efficace
comment vous êtes efficace comment vous
faites pour bien distinguer pour
censurer et qui surtout censure veille
pour répondre aux critiques de big
brother d'algorithmes qui vont contrôler
les propos comment vous faites si je
vous instruis ce qu'on peut faire
confiance aux plateformes sujet sur
votre éditeur aussi jouer sur votre
twitter et que vous
vous savez quoi ça épate de l'insuline
c'est du très directe pour que ce soit
immédiatement retirée par la plateforme
c'est assez automatiquement en règle
générale faut que ce soit automatisé
encore plus et faire en sorte que ce
soit enlevé après les opinions outre les
discussions sur les opinions
la réalité c'est une dans le texte de
laëtitia bien en aucun cas on remet en
cause des opinions est par exemple
l'antisémitisme c'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit en france votre et donc
ça doit être immédiatement voix qui a
été votée a besoin d'aller d'aller
attendre des semaines et des semaines
si on attendait semaine c'est ça le
poison des réseaux sociaux
merci sylvain mayer ce sera donc le mot
de la fin merci d'avoir été notre invité
on se retrouve le 10 janvier sur ce
plateau d'ici la joyeuse fait qu'il y
ait une trêve de noël ou pas ciao
[Musique]